c'est ici à l'ancien palais de justice
de fort-de-france qu'un musée d'art
contemporain devrait voir le jour dans
cinq à six ans la décision a été actée
sans les voix de l'opposition qui a voté
contre lors de la plénière de la ctm la
semaine dernière coût de l'opération 23
millions d'euros 23 millions d'euros ça
englobe le bâtiment les travaux de
réhabilitation du bâtiment
c'est le lieu idéal parce qu'il ya un
effet de centralité nous sommes au coeur
de fort de france
c'est une ville qui est de plus en plus
visités par les touristes de croisière
et les touristes d'une façon générale
nous sommes tout près d'autres lieux
culturels emblématique de la martinique
mais les choses ne sont pas si simples
l'ancien palais de justice aujourd'hui
espace camille darsières abrite les
ateliers du sermac il n'est pas question
pour la ville de déminage et de coups de
baguette magique
même si le terrain appartient la city
cet espace est fait l'objet d'une
convention tripartite en 2004 2005 entre
le conseil général de l'époque
l'état et la ville le conseil général a
mis à disposition ce lieu pour en faire
un espace dédié aux cultures afro
caribéenne
un hommage à aimé césaire la ville de
fort-de-france et le sermac n'a pas de
raison de déménager je vous comme je
voulais dit il il ya eu cette convention
qui mettait à disposition il ya des
travaux qui ont été faits il ya eu des
propositions d'achat qui ont été faites
par la ville
à ce jour nous n'avons pas reçu de
réponse il n'y a pas de polémique
le temps que nous réalisions les travaux
que nous réalisions ce musée on aura le
temps de permettre aux ateliers du
sermac y sont installés dans cet endroit
en ce moment on aura le temps de
permettre aux ateliers du sermac de
déménager et de retrouver le haut lieu
in initial et voilà un nouveau bras de
fer en perspective entre la 7e et la
ville de fort de france comme parfum de
déjà vu